here we go kickoff time I'm always
playing black against a snook does it
sound like I'm whining it might be
because I am okay f-for bird is the word
bird is the word
bird is the word it's not the word ah c4
ok c5 mimicking game ah wait a second
wait a second wait a second how can I
deal with that I don't know if I want to
get into what do I not want to get into
let's do this let's see if the knight is
gonna play do f3 I'm being sneaky here I
want to control this square and I think
I'm gonna have control over it let's see
ok we'll have control over I was
planning Knight f3 a pin now we have
this and we are entering in what what
territory are we in right now so hmm I
might want to just give up my Bishop
Bishop here if age 3 take this and then
expand on the B file hmm f4 f5 could be
a bug that could be a bug definitely
can't it I'm gonna give it a shot focus
on the dark squares is the plan so if f3
well I guess I go back to right here so
now there's 7th rank or 2nd rank issues
and I think I get into a position now
where I should play this let's do that I
don't want this push to be played and I
think my opponent would be a bit more
cautious about playing f4 right now
because of how I could be responding I
think this is a good start and what next
my Bishop is actually in a spot to
facilitate not only be 5 but maybe to
just play to c6 2
take out the night I'm not so sure I
could rely upon my knight on f6 anymore
so this is kind of the direction I want
to be and I think rook b8 b5 stuff again
since this F pawn moved it's not just
the diagonal that has been weakened but
also second ranks so the can maybe be
cut off towards an endgame if I plant a
rook on that second rank one pig as I
will often no reference so now this move
is being prepped and what should I be
doing about it well I'm not really sure
what about pawn push now now that's not
really working is it actually maybe um
maybe this Knight here let's try it I
don't know if it's right pressure on
this so right now I've captures that the
knight has to recapture here this has to
be a bit inconvenient to tolerate a
knight right here it's stopping actually
my first thought was maybe after this
move the knight could play here and now
I pretty much have to just come back so
okay I realized that but what I'm hoping
to get now is this square for my pieces
should f4 be played I want to get to
this square so I think I know the
direction I want to be in after f4 I'm
pretty sure I just have to take right
away and I really can't do that right
away okay let me do this and then I'm
preparing Knight d7 to e5 because I
think this is the only direction for my
opponent to go and they just gave up
their darks for a bishop really whoa I
can't be right can it okay now where
would I like to be this this can't be
right there's no way that this could be
right right I controlled this square
after F pawn pushes it's only this night
that I have to be cautious of I have
these squares available and I think with
the bishop hair
I should be looking to open things up so
let me do this move instead of b6 there
could be take stakes and then a 4 B 5
both temple gaining moves but I will get
this square if this pawn moves I have
the c5 square I'm looking to just
capture and then maybe have this pawn
move at some point I don't have this
move let's see how my opponent
recaptures the rook okay
counter-attack pressure on this pawn and
I believe after a5 my opponent is going
to be in some hot water I get this c5
square and I'm able to put pressure a
significant amount of pressure on this
pun and I believe it's it's kind of
tough okay I take here and now my bishop
posting up on e5 as a monster is it not
or even right here placing this knight
in a pin that's actually pretty
appealing or none of the above how about
I take here no I like placing that night
in the pin actually hmm there is pawn
push and then my rook is hit so maybe I
should just play here and cope with the
knight on this square I'm gonna do this
I think my knight is really good
actually there is no Knight here because
I have the pressure on this pawn so
let's do this first stop this potential
pawn sack and then Bishop to h6 or even
Queen to out to one of these two squares
these dark squares have to this can't be
right right my bishop here there's two
pieces of greater value on the same diag
and all difficult pin to get out of in
other words maybe a Bishop to e3 to give
a check at some point maybe the a file
opens up or maybe even my Brooke can
contribute to putting pressure on this
d3 pawn after takes Queen takes Queen
takes rook takes I have pressure it's my
rook is incredibly active and this
Knight it remains out of play and is a
tactical vulnerability and so too is
this rook or this bishop so I think I
just take here or do I
how about well push push no it's
do that how about Queen here no there's
night there so if I take there's gonna
be a queen recapture and then there's
pressure on this I don't want to drop
this pond let's not drop that pond so
place the knight in a pin now how about
I'm gonna go with this knowing that
there could be like a knight move here
okay I think I want to just get rid of
that Knight get rid of the night before
it posts right here guard this pawn it's
gotta be inconvenient right or the
Knights gonna play here soon or
something but I have something on the a
file let me do this right now I got that
a pawn my knight is a really strong
piece right Queen takes here is there
gonna be night right here no that I
could get this it interferes with the
bishop view of the pond so if Queen
takes here do I take the pawn or do I
play here first because I don't want to
work myself into a pin on this file
right here so I think I actually win
material now right it's just winning
material what am I missing here there's
a nasty pin that occurs if something's
taken right here my Queen's in a good
spot am I one of these bishops is gonna
be off the board real soon and there's
nothing against my King it's the knight
if anything that can maybe caused me
some problems is it going to cause me
some problems I don't think so I'm not
going to take the bishop because my
opponent would then be out of a pin I
mean look to advance my development and
I could do that with this rook move the
knight is still pinned and if there's
bishop takes I recaptured the rook and
then the knight is lost pawn push allows
just pawn takes 40 seconds for white you
I'm the one that's behind in time here
so I don't I don't see any uh okay now
actually I'll take that bishop or should
I yeah actually cuz now I'm on this
what's that move
did I miss something here don't tell me
I missed something here are they just
trying to be sneaky
there's no perpetual check here that is
a move I did consider I don't have very
much time I guess I better just go with
this
there's no perpetual there's definitely
no pipette so I guess this is the best
practical try best practical try my King
could definitely find a safe haven over
here somewhere takes a little bit of
work but okay now let's just make sure
what my rook coming over to defend
against this sort of stuff and now and
now what next
okay there's this Queen trade coming up
soon and very very soon unavoidable
Queen's are off Queens are off and let's
stop that King from doing anything
kick the King back support this pawn and
then everything should be alright so
alright good game
rook takes h3 yeah let me back up let's
see
again this um this early move right here
d6 if I let's say run with night C
knight c6 and my opponent plays like
nighty to d4 is gonna be played and it's
difficult for me to get in this d5 like
move because white just already has so
much control over it so I was trying to
tweak the move order here and I was
taking into account the Knight f3 move
by playing this d6 move I want to be
able to take that night out and get
control over d4 was basically the name
of the game and at this point I'm
already assured of it I have enough
control over it
actually right now soon as I play this
knight move I don't have control over it
maybe there is d4 opportunities but it
was kind of baby stepped right there
which isn't uh which isn't necessarily a
bad thing so the bishop is there to
facilitate as soon as this move is there
you know as soon as there's enough
pieces there that's why I played the
more committal move e5 I don't know well
really it's this this is the I just
don't know about what move don't I know
about oh this one right here I think
there's something to be said for that
move I think maybe pawn push right now
is best and I think I'll be needing to
play f5 in response to it because
otherwise I run the risk of just f5 and
maybe there's some issues against my
king king side here so g3 and chases my
knight back but now it's like I'm just
getting in a position now to occupy this
square as soon as this advance comes and
that's really the only direction Y can
be going in so I'm assured a good
position for my minor piece that's the
direct result of having this pawn on g4
instead of g3 so again looking a bit
more closely at that I think this is a
big turning point and I guess another
one is I don't know if taking this
Knight is the right thing to do
how about f4 right now keeping this dark
square bishop around but in any event I
still think I have liked this night
repositioning to e5 it would be a little
bit more difficult however if f4 and I
take and the bishop recaptures by having
the Bishop on f4 putting pressure on d6
I don't have this Knight repositioned to
d7 just yet because I mask my Queens
view of the d6 pawn so I think what a
difference a pawn move can make right
how about just not g4 but rather just f4
right now and then if I capture you have
the option to now recapture and in doing
so you take away the e5 square my pieces
can no longer pivot about on that e5
square so when g3 is g4 is played I can
rely upon e 5 the e5 square for my
pieces because f4 is really the only
direction to go in
but yeah so in other words do without g4
I think it would be a much different
game